- We've been trained since kindergarten
in our government schools
to regard the media
as authoritative and
as hard-working people
fighting for the little guy
and trying to present the truth
yet we see many, many
examples of the little guy,
Nicholas Sandmann's a
very obvious example,
those cadets who were
playing the circle game.
Here's an easy example, the
guy who photoshopped CNN
into that gif with Trump wrestling them,
CNN said we reserve the right
to sue you, that's not--
- Yeah, to hunt him down
and destroy him for creating a meme.
- That's not looking
out for the little guy.
That's looking out for number one.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- This is The Rubin Report and according
to a Russian bot farm I'm Dave Rubin.
Quick reminder guys to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
which gives you a 5% chance
of actually seeing our videos
in the feed, pretty good.
Joining me today is the
author of "The New Right"
the host of the YOUR WELCOME podcast
and the man that I've dubbed
the Willy Wonka of politics,
Michael Malice, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Thanks so much.
- Well sir, where to start?
I think your outfit.
- Yeah.
- It reminds me of
somebody, a former guest.
I didn't see you until two minutes ago.
You walked in here wearing
this gorgeous little thing.
- Yeah, I've been known
for this look for years.
- [Dave] Is that right?
- And all of a sudden
I get phone calls,
who's this woman, Tulsi,
who's been dressing like you?
She's so nuts, she even
put a streak in her hair
to pass as me even more.
And I looked this up, she
says she's from the state
called Hawaii, Hawaii,
I've never heard this.
There's a bunch of volcanoes
in the middle of the Atlantic
and we're supposed to
believe that this is a state.
They live on volcanoes,
rain of liquid metal.
They check the weather and this is people,
this is how they gerrymander
the Electoral College.
And now they're trying to
say Guam's a state, Guam.
I asked my friend, where's Guam?
Point it to me on the map.
He points to this little island
by the boot, that's Sicily.
- Are you saying Guam?
- Guam.
Guam, Guam?
- Have you ever found,
they're making up words
and making them states.
This is how the fake
news media gets over it.
Anyway, getting back to her
campaign I think she's great.
- [Dave] Yes.
- I've been following her very closely,
and I think it's reprehensible
what's being done to
people like Tulsi Gabbard,
the congresswoman from so-called Hawaii
and all the other democratic outliers.
This is a wonderful change in our politics
where so many people are
realizing the nature of the enemy.
- All right, so we're gonna
talk about all of that stuff
but because a huge portion of our people
just listen to audio I do feel
that I have to describe
what you're wearing.
- Hunky.
- You are in a white leisure suit.
- It's a suit, this is business,
how's it a leisure suit?
- It seems like a leisure suit.
You look like Leisure Suit Larry
or you look like Larry
from Three's Company
or something like that or--
- We can do this dance
if you want to--
- Or Don Johnson
or John Travolta.
- Don Johnson, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- White suit.
But you are, no, this is very much
the Tulsi Gabbard white suit.
- No.
This is the Michael Malice look
that Tulsi Gabbard appropriated.
- That Tulsi appropriated.
- Thank you.
- Yes, yes, yes, no okay,
you hit a whole bunch of stuff there.
The reason that I wanted to have you back
'cause as you know I find you to be
one of the most interesting
political thinkers out there.
I do.
- [Michael] Thank you, that's appreciated.
- There you go, paying you
a compliment right up front.
You consistently strike me as
someone that is always like
really on what I would
say is the forward fringe
of what's happening
culturally and politically
and the whole shebang so let's start
where you just started there,
that there suddenly seems
to be a couple outliers with the Dems.
And the DNC or the powers
that be or the gatekeepers
or The New York Times
or CNN or whatever else
you wanna call that, not
too happy about them.
- Yeah, for a long time
conservatives often get things wrong
and I criticize them very
heavily on my Twitter,
and when I speak of them I do so
with great love and affection.
They have always argued that the media
is a wing of the DNC, and
what we're seeing recently now
is it's more accurate to say that the DNC
is a wing of the media because
you'll see things like,
anyone who deviates, as
you mentioned earlier,
from basically the media's
party line is crushed.
Let's give an example, I'm a
Democratic congressman, right,
let's suppose from Hawaii or some other,
or from a real state.
- Some other magical place.
- A state that actually exists.
- Yes.
- And for three years
my constituents have heard CNN and MSNBC
talk about Russia
collusion, Russia collusion,
Trump's Hitler, Trump's
this, Trump's that.
How am I as a politician
supposed to go back
to my constituents and
say with a straight face,
I think Trump's the worst president ever.
I think he's a racist,
concentration camps, despicable,
he's ruined the presidency
but I don't think this
is grounds for removing him from office.
I don't have that space,
so it's pretty clear
who's the one who is leading the charge
and who is following it,
and for a long time again
conservatives thought this was
Republican versus Democrat.
And now we're seeing
that it's establishment
versus outsider because
we're seeing it how
they treated Tulsi, we're seeing
it how they treated Bernie,
and Andrew Yang, that's the special one.
'Cause Andrew Yang is hardly
some wide-eyed radical, right.
He's a wonk.
He's in many ways akin to
Mitt Romney in certain ways.
He wears the math lapel pin,
he wants people to succeed.
- Yeah, he's a business
guy and mostly a centrist.
- Right.
- Probably, or not probably
certainly way too big
government for you, right?
- Sure.
- But at least you think
he's a sort of functional human being
and doesn't come out of the machine.
- Right, and he is, there
have been many cases
where he's basically been
treated as if he doesn't exist.
They use the wrong photo for him.
He tweeted out that every other campaign
gets to have people who
represent them on your shows
but with him it has to be him personally.
So when people on the left
are starting to realize,
oh, this isn't about
Republican versus Democrat
this is about us versus them
and you can just as easily
be a Democrat and be a
them eyes are opening
and that is a very,
very healthy phenomenon.
I always say that the
corporate press is the enemy
of the people, and I think
that's the moderate position.
- What is the corporate press really?
Like, what is the psychological makeup
of the corporate press that
causes this whole thing?
- Sure, so basically what you
have are the universities,
and that's where the evil starts.
And we've been trained since kindergarten
in our government schools
to regard the media
as authoritative and as hardworking people
fighting for the little guy
and trying to present the truth
yet we see many, many
examples of the little guy,
Nicholas Sandmann's a
very obvious example,
those cadets who were
playing the circle game.
Here's an easy example, the
guy who photoshopped CNN
into that gif with Trump wrestling them,
CNN said we reserve the right
to sue you, that's not--
- Yeah, to hunt him down and destroy him
for creating a meme, yeah.
- That's not looking
out for the little guy,
that's looking out for number one, so--
- Do you, I've asked a
bunch of guests this,
but do you think there's a
moment where something changed?
'Cause it wasn't always this horrible.
- [Michael] It was always this horrible.
- Now I get it's being exposed
now more because we can
all immediately tweet out
the truth the second
they pump out the lie,
but do you think there were
some other seminal moments
somewhere along the road that turned it?
- It was always this horrible,
and this is what conservatives
don't appreciate.
We all learn in high school
about William Randolph Hearst,
the Spanish-American
War, remember the Maine
and yellow journalism
and then they just kinda,
the record scratched and
now we're into today.
I have a big thread on Twitter,
Walter Duranty's the prime example.
He was a New York Times man
covering the Soviet Union,
and while Stalin intentionally
committed a genocide
via starvation of Ukraine, the Holodomor,
he was putting out dispatches
all the time saying
there's no problem, if there is a problem
it is malevolent propaganda.
He said the Russian people,
oh it's a little tough
but they're tightening their belts.
Tightening their belts is
a very interesting idiom
in this context, and what
Stalin did to these people
is if you were a kulak
which meant landowner
but pretty soon meant anyone,
if you had any food in your
home that was for the people.
They ransacked the house and took it.
And if you weren't starving
that's how they knew
you were hiding food and
that's who they targeted.
So they would beat people mercilessly,
they would tear their house upside down,
kick 'em out in the streets to starve.
And there was another reporter
who, and going to this area
was forbidden by the Soviet government.
There was a reporter who
jumped off the train,
went to a few villages, reported
back what was happening,
these horrors and Duranty
was like, oh, you know,
he's just an anti-Soviet agitator.
So this has been going
on for a very long time.
They've always been hard-core.
I call then Jihadis
without the testosterone.
They have been, this is
a very demented ideology
that will do everything in its power
to maintain its hold
on power, and only now
that they've been fact
checked in real time
and called out on their
tactics in real time
are people realizing, oh, I'm
just gonna say one more point.
I had this tweet yesterday.
It's not about the corruption,
it's about the depravity.
If it was just, hey, I'm hiring my brother
and he's getting paid too
much money to sit on his ass
no one would care.
- Yeah, right.
We know they do that, that's fine.
- That's fine.
- We let that go.
No one cares.
- It's like--
Right, yeah, yeah, no one cares.
This is about Amy Robach
and Jeffrey Epstein.
When you have a network that knows
that someone is engaged in
the sexual trade of children
and their concern is
not getting an interview
with Meghan Markle, and
when this is exposed
instead of coming clean
it's, let's target the person
who revealed this footage
and get them fired
at the network which they went to.
- It's a lot.
It's a lot, but what do you think
about the sort of psychological
condition of these people?
Like, when I watch all of
these clips of CNN anchors
saying the reverse of the truth
or Cuomo tweeting out that,
you know, look at the way the
right attacks Greta Thunberg
when he went after Nick
Sandmann or just a kid.
All of this nonsense that they never stop.
They seem completely
psychologically unable to stop.
And that strikes me as very weird.
You know, I sit with a lot of people.
If you were to say something to me
that was patently true that
was against what I believe
I would struggle with it,
we would work it through.
I would ask you some
questions, but I know myself,
I would probably change my mind
if you made a compelling case.
- We now in a point where there's a lot
of compelling evidence that
these people lie endlessly
and nothing ever stops them.
- I don't even know that
I would use the word lie
and here's why, I talk about
this heavily in the book.
I regard what I call the
evangelical left, these types.
When you're adherent to
a fundamentalist creed
facts do not change your opinion.
In fact contradictory facts
make you double down, right.
So if you are talking to someone
who is a hardcore creationist
and you show them fossils
they're not going to wonder
if creationism's wrong.
They will regard this as
evidence that their willpower
and faith is correct
and this is just a test.
And it's the exact same psychology.
The contemporary, and I
don't regard all leftists
in this vein, I regard this specifically
as these jihadi types,
they have this vision
that they are the ones who
are going to save America
and the world and it's a degeneration
of what happened 100 years
ago called the social gospel
which was the premise that
instead of an individual
being saved which is a basic
premise of Christianity
it's the nation that has to be saved.
However, when you have this worldview
that a nation's soul can be saved
or the Earth's soul can be saved
that means there is no space
that is outside your purview.
That means whatever someone watches,
whatever someone does at home,
anything aspect of your life is subject
to their domination and control.
So it is an absolute
totalitarian worldview
and they admit it.
You know, other than
maybe perhaps abortion
if you ask them what is a
place where it's not your place
to judge they will just
kinda, their eyes will shake.
- Yeah, well they're Thanos, right?
I mean, this is what I
keep saying every week now.
- Thanos was successful.
- (laughs) But they might be successful.
They're gonna have to kill a
lot of people to do it, right?
- You know Rand, Ayn Rand
was on Donahue in 1979.
- [Dave] I've seen the
clip a million times yeah.
- Yeah, and he asks her,
"Why are you so hard on these people?
"Why don't you just say, I disagree?"
And she goes, "Because I look at them.
"They don't hesitate to
sacrifice entire nations."
So the people who advocate for Venezuela
and the horrors that are going on there.
I mean, you know, animals being eaten,
kids lying in pools of blood
'cause you don't have hospital
supplies during childbirth.
No one who pushed for this was like, wow,
I made a huge misjudgment, there's--
- Yeah, you gotta keep
going 'cause otherwise
you have to turn it on yourself.
- Right, and there's
never any accountability.
Juliana Reed who
allegedly by her own words
called the FBI about
tweets that she sent out
is still gainfully
employed and the day after
this brouhaha between Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
where if Bernie had said,
I don't think a woman
can be elected, they're
portraying it as him saying
I don't think a woman
should be elected, she had--
- Yeah, yeah, there's huge distinction
that everybody like ran, shot across.
- Yeah, and intentionally muddled.
She had a body language expert on to show
that Bernie's like, and
here was the amazing part.
The body language expert's
like, when he was asked
this question he shrunk and got nervous.
He's on national television
being told, being asked to say,
is his good friend lying about him.
Who's not gonna get nervous?
- So when you watch a moment like that,
the can a woman be elected moment
between the two of them and then suddenly
the audio leaks right
after and Elizabeth Warren
walks up to him and says,
"You just called me a liar."
- [Michael] You called me a
lair on national television!
- When you see that do you think
that the entire thing is staged?
Because that struck me as Elizabeth Warren
somehow coordinated something with CNN
so that she knew the mics were on
and she could just get a little more juice
because they really do hate Bernie.
Now, I despise all of
Bernie's ideas, I think--
- [Michael] All of them?
- Uh, we'll get into that in a little bit
but I would say 90% of them
probably but we'll do that.
That she though coordinated something,
that something felt really off about that.
Like, oh this is just where they happen
to have left the mics on.
You know what it's like to have a mic on
and be wandering around
and the amount of stuff
that gets dropped--
- So one of the things
I talk heavily in my
work in "The New Right"
is the concept of the red pill.
And for those who don't
know, the red pill's
from the documentary The Matrix.
And once you are red pilled
that is the understanding
that what we see as presented as truth
in the corporate press is in fact
a carefully constructed narrative
designed to keep some very
unpleasant people in power.
So a lot of people are trained to think
of a television screen as a window, right?
So when you're doing what you're doing
that's a red pill and like wait a minute,
what's the backstory that is leading me
to see what's happening here?
If I had to guess I would guess
she just didn't care one way or another.
That she was, that he probably
did say something similar
but in an innocuous way,
hey, do you think a woman
would get elected, and obviously woman
are gonna have an uphill battle.
It's never happened before.
And she's portraying it as,
you know, oh poor victim me.
And she just wanted to confront him
to look tough on the record.
I think she genuinely
felt she does not handle
a counterpunch very well.
Elizabeth Warren is not a
dummy, she taught at Harvard.
She's a bright woman,
you know what I mean?
- I'm not so sure
teaching at Harvard makes one bright.
- I mean, you forget how
smart the average person is.
So I'm going by that standard.
So you have her with Trump
for a year take the DNA test,
take the DNA test, take the DNA test.
She takes it and she
goes, there I took it.
And he goes, who cares?
So he broke this woman's brain,
and on some level I feel
a little bit bad for her,
but the beauty of social media is
after that exchange
happened all her tweets
are being bombed with snakes.
- With snakes.
Snake emoji replies.
- Yeah.
By Sanders supporters, and now
he's taken all her support.
- So let's talk about that a little bit
'cause what I think you really
are sort of an expert at
is like the internet, the
underbelly of the internet
side of this, so when you see
a moment like that, you know,
the Sanders Warren
thing and then literally
it was just thousands
and thousands of people.
Whether you like trolling or not,
but it was, right, it was lefties.
Well, I find the Bernie people,
and I'm critical of Bernie
obviously especially on Twitter.
I find the Bernie people
to be the most unbearable
on Twitter, the most hostile and mean.
And it's weird because
they have, you know,
most of them have roses in their emojis
and they have their gender pronouns
and everything's about
diversity and tolerance
but I find them to be the worst,
but they really turned on
her, but when you see a moment
like that and then you see
the people with the snakes
come in and all the fighting after that,
that's like your game, right?
Like, you love this world.
- This is my porn, yeah.
Like any time you have
this conflict and strife
it's beautiful, it's very healthy.
I'm very much for as much
political division as possible.
I think when the parties get together
or when one party gets
together you have things
that are abominations
like Obamacare or war.
This is what happens when
the two gangs drop their arms
and decide to shake hands.
- So do you think if we
just had sort of an endless
internal battle within the parties
so they could sort of
not really do anything
because they'd just be internally fighting
that that would put us in a
better political situation
'cause really not much could happen?
- Yeah, and I think it's
gonna lead eventually
to kind of the breakup
of the United States
because this country has been united
with basically thumbtacks and
strings since the beginning,
and there's no reason
for two or more cultures
who have increasing contempt
an inability to speak
to each other to be part of one polity.
- Was this the inevitable
conclusion, do you think,
of the melting pot 'cause it's worked here
better than it's worked anywhere else.
Do you think that's a fair premise?
- I don't think it's because the melting.
I mean, look at the Civil War.
I mean, this is has
been from the beginning.
At the very beginning it was the North
that wanted to secede because culturally
they're very opposed and
actually before the melting pot
the argument was, well we're
the Anglo-Saxons in the North
and they're Teutonic
or Scottish, whatever,
I don't remember what
they were in the South.
- But we got through all of it.
I mean, we had a Civil War
and then we became a united nation.
- We didn't get through it, no we didn't.
Because for decades,
the South was regarded
as the subordinate conquered land
whipping boy and to this day,
you just saw that on CNN,
people just regard the South
as this kind of degenerate version
of the rest of the United States.
- Sure, I'm not saying there aren't elites
and people that mock
each other and all that,
but we have one functional country
and you can travel to the
South and travel to the North
and do commerce and all of those things.
Like I get it, I'm not
saying there aren't tensions
and all that, but even within that
we've still remained basically peaceful.
- Sure, and I think one
of the big misconceptions,
and this is another idea, is
that if there's going to be
any separation or self-segregation
is has to be violent.
And a great counterexample
of this is Brexit.
You know, Britain's leaving
the EU, they're doing it.
It's gonna be tough, it's
gonna be a long divorce,
but they're doing it peacefully.
So I think increasingly
there is an understanding
that there's no need, and social
media is speeding this up.
It's causing people to go
to their logical extremes
in terms of politics and
there's less room in the middle
which is exactly what
I like because I think
when you're in the middle that means
you don't really have any principles.
- So if this thing gets to
what I guess you would say
is its inevitable
conclusion then what are--
- Not inevitable, I'm hoping,
that's where I'm pushing it
but I don't think it's inevitable.
- Oh, you don't think it's inevitable.
Okay, so if it gets to the conclusion
that Michael Malice sees
own the road, what is that?
- Freedom, it's not having the
biggest government on Earth
taking all this money out of you.
You know, obviously
the ultimate conclusion
would hopefully be an anarchist system,
but we've got a long
way to go to tear down
this Goliath that's been
built up over centuries.
And I think it's wonderful
that Trump and the Democrats
are both bringing such
disdain and disrepute
to the electoral system
and democracy in general.
- Is that the ultimate flaw of the lefties
that for what you may agree
with them on the parts
where Bernie will talk
about crony capitalism
or that sort of stuff that you don't like
or the big money in politics and all that,
that the answer is always
exactly what the problem is.
His answer is always give it more money.
His answer is always give it more power
where a more libertarian
answer, your answer,
I think something closer
to my answer would be,
well you starve the freaking beast.
You just starve it till
it has no more power.
- No, I think their central
problem is their obsession
with equality at any cost because even
if they weren't involved in government
they're still going to be pushing
this kind of bizarre equality agenda
which has deathly consequences.
- Did you see I was just on Tucker Carlson
because Elizabeth Warren
wants a 50% female
and non-binary cabinet
which is very important
I would imagine--
- But there's more nefarious consequences.
You had in Florida with
that school shooting.
Basically this kid was telling them
that I'm going to shoot up the school.
And they said, well
sane kids don't do this.
We're gonna put you in special ed.
And then you, I forgot,
Nikolas Cruz his name.
Andrew Pollack, his dad,
wrote a book about this
because his daughter was killed.
So then they don't want to report him
because then you have the
school to prison pipeline.
They want to have the good
statistics and eventually
what the logic of the left is,
if one person has a problem
everyone has to have that
problem because that's equality.
And he came and true to his
word he shot up that school
and it's like, we all saw this coming
but because you are
obsessed with this idea
that everyone has to be treated
the same or treated fairly,
it leads to death, it
leads to the meat grinder.
- So even though you like this idea
of the internal fighting
do you think, like,
AOC's been a making a point which, again,
this is someone who I disagree
with on most of the stuff
but I think she does get one
every now and again which is
she's basically been saying,
why am I in the same party as Joe Biden?
That does make sense to me.
These people have really nothing,
no matter how woke Biden
tries to become now,
he's trying at this end
stage which is sort of sad,
but it's like, they shouldn't be
in the same party, should they?
- Well I mean, America's very unique
because most of the
European countries have
parliamentary systems where
they have like nine parties.
Like in Iceland right now there's a party
that's just dedicated to
people with disabilities
and they have seats in the parliament.
So they get that specific
and issue driven.
The fact that we only have--
- Which has its own set of problems.
- Of course it does,
and it's hard to form
coalitions and so on.
The fact that we only have two parties
with a country that's what, 350 million
and those are supposed to
cover everyone's views.
This is an example of why
politics is landline technology
for a post cellphone world.
Back in the '80s every terrible comedian
would joke about, oh there's Coke
and now there's Diet Coke
and there's Cherry Coke.
What's next, caffeine
free Cherry Diet Coke.
Yeah, you could have that
and that's not a problem,
but why do I have to have two choices
and those choices are Coke or Pepsi
when I prefer not to drink soda at all.
And that is not an option
and it's getting hard.
And in Europe we're
seeing this very heavily,
the fragmentation, it's
getting very, very hard
to form coalitions of 51% and
that's wonderful because--
- Yeah, Israel's had what,
17 elections in a row.
- It's something crazy.
- Yeah.
So it's a very healthy thing
that people are regarding the two parties
as not being representative
of them and their views.
- So for a guy that's
obviously not on the left
that doesn't particularly
subscribe to those ideas
what would a sane left look like?
'Cause I think maybe you
would want some level
of a sane left, right?
- I think there's a lot of
sane left, I think if you are--
- Yeah, so what is a sane left?
- All it takes is being
red pilled, recognizing
'cause here's why I can
talk to the Bernie people.
Here's why I can talk to the Tulsi people
if I ever found this
Hawaii imaginary place,
here's why I could talk
to the Yang people.
- Well tell it to people
who are listening right now.
- Yeah.
- I don't know
if the Bernie people are.
- Because once you realize
that we are being manipulated, lied to,
and tried to be controlled,
and we're also told
that anyone who says these
things is a conspiracy theorist.
So right away you don't
have to listen to him.
Even though the Weinstein
conspiracy's been demonstrated,
the Epstein conspiracy's
been demonstrated,
the Constitution was
written as a conspiracy.
They met in secret and,
basically threw out the law and said,
we're just gonna overthrow the government.
All these things were conspiracies.
Once you realize this
then you could have an
honest conversation.
I have not had that Bernie
experience that you had,
but you're more higher profile than I am,
but that is a starting
point where it's like,
let's talk honestly instead of
having these two-minute hates
trying to destroy people
on a personal level
which maybe they do, I don't understand.
Again, I'm not familiar
with the Bernie crowd,
but that is the starting
point of a sane left
because there's--
- But then what is it actually
like what are the ideas?
- I'm just gonna say,
no one I know would have a
problem with a lefty who says,
I believe in a welfare
state, I don't wanna live
in a country where people
are starving in the street.
I don't think someone should be bankrupt
because they got cancer,
and I want my kids
even if they're destitute to be able
to be able to have a
decent quality education.
That's a sane lefty.
- Yeah.
- And I don't think anyone--
- Well, I'd say that's an
old-school liberal basically.
Wants a little more government
than an ancap wants.
But it's to help people.
- Right.
The libertarian people would say,
well you're actually not helping them.
You're keeping them on the dole.
- Sure, but that's an
easy conversation to have.
That's very different from,
this kind of fundamentalist
faith where overnight
we have to care not
only about trans people
but specifically transgender bathrooms.
Not any other trans issue,
this is the one trans issue,
and if you don't care about
this one specific subissue
of this greater issue you can
be run out of polite society.
That is coming from a place
of domination and control
not a place of empathy and sympathy.
- It's a really great way of
looking at it because remember
when that whole transgender
bathroom thing happened in,
was that in North Carolina?
- Yeah.
And then suddenly the NBA said,
we're not gonna have the All
Star game here and Obama said,
we're gonna cut funds to the
state and all of those things.
And it's like, guys, we're
trying to have some level
of a decent conversation and you guys
have now taken this to,
we're literally talking
about the power of the federal government
over transgender bathrooms
and that's the dangerous part
here for most people I think.
- Yeah, I think people, for a
long time the corporate press
has been very good at using persuasion.
And now that the animus toward
them is at all-time highs
and hopefully will keep
escalating their mask is dropping
and they're demonstrating
they're perfectly comfortable
using their B move which
is force if necessary.
- Do you think they think
they're getting away with it?
So a great example of this
would be just what happened
to Joe Rogan in the last little bit.
So Rogan basically endorsed Bernie.
- [Michael] He didn't even.
- But not even quite, right.
- [Michael] He said I'd vote for him.
- Right, so everyone was saying
it was an endorsement but
it was basically like,
I like the guy, he's been
consistent over the years.
Something like that, and CNN from CNN's
main verified Twitter
account literally said
something to the effect of,
Bernie Sanders under heat
because he takes the endorsement
of homophobic, racist,
Islamophobic comedian Joe Rogan.
And it's like, you don't have
to love Rogan and I get it.
He's been included on scary charts
that you and I have been included on.
- You know these charts,
they're out there, sometimes
they put little lines
next to each other
and then it's like, oh my
God, you talked about--
- But that's not a conspiracy theory.
- Right, yeah, you're
right, exactly, exactly.
And then, yeah, all right,
we'll put that aside for a sec.
But when you see that it's like, whew,
they got almost nothing left now.
- But this is the tactic of
theirs that I called out.
I have a master thread on Twitter.
It's called as an aside.
So for example if I was describing you
as someone who's an
objective or even biased.
Let's suppose I'm a biased
journalist and I don't like you.
I would still say Dave Rubin, comma,
who is a popular podcaster,
comma, said blah, blah, blah.
Right, that's an accurate framing.
Their first sentence is always to ascribe
the most nefarious framing
possible to this person.
- Right wing, far right.
- The reader right away knows
this is someone to avoid.
Joe Rogan, comma, who has a
history of making homophobic
and racist jokes, comma.
If you had to describe Joe
Rogan look at his Wikipedia.
That's not what he's known as.
MMA, comedian, podcaster.
No one would define him that
way unless you are telling
and training your audience what to think.
It's completely disingenuous
and that's the difference
between having a bias
and having an agenda.
If it was a bias, they said
Joe Rogan, popular podcast
however he's got controversy
for this you show both sides.
That's not what they're doing.
They're telling you front and center
this person is the enemy
and you should shun him.
And what's beautiful is
look who the corporate press
has needlessly alienated
through their chicanery.
Rogan fans, Tulsi fans,
Bernie fans, Andrew Yang fans,
Trump fans, Kobe fans, Don
Imus fans, it's amazing.
They can't help themselves because again
when you have a fundamentalist
faith you are certain
that you're on the side of the angels.
- That is a tough one to fight, huh?
A fine mess for us.
- It's easy because they're delusional
and not in touch with reality.
There's an asymmetry between
truth and lies, right?
If I tell you 100 truths and one lie
you're gonna look at me as a liar.
If I kill one person and
never kill anyone else
I'm still a murderer, right?
So if I'm presenting myself
as an objective news organization
and I'm caught once, twice, 12 times
the average person who doesn't
have any political persuasion
one way or another will not
look at me as trustworthy.
And once trust is lost
it is almost impossible
to be regained.
- So with that in mind
let's talk about this clip
that went viral, the CNN clip.
- Oh yes.
- It's Don Lemon
who's their main anchor.
Don used to be a friend of
mine, he was on this show.
I'm not here to throw
the guy under the bus.
- Don Lemon, comma, who
used to be a Rubin guest.
- Yeah exactly, who must be
on a chart with Dave Rubin.
And it was Rick Wilson who is a,
is he a Republican strategist?
- Ostensibly, yes.
Supposedly, right?
- Yeah, he thinks he's--
That's what it says under his name,
and the other person was...
- Fareed, I forget his name
and I'm gonna sound racist if I try.
- All right and some other
guy but it's three of them.
They've got their heads in boxes on CNN.
And can you just describe what happened
and then the reaction
to it 'cause it's such
a perfect example of all of this.
- There was a lot to unpack in this clip.
So Rick Wilson was making the
joke that Trump is so dumb
that he couldn't find
Ukraine on a map, right.
This is 101 humor and Don Lemon--
- (laughs) So original.
- There's this condition
called Angelman syndrome,
and when kids have it
they can't help but laugh
all the time and it's kinda disturbing
'cause they'll be in their
crib just cracking up.
And he just loses it as
if it's the funniest thing
he's ever heard and I'm
like, this is first grade
playground stuff, it's not clever.
And they start going off on
how all these Trump voters
are like, uh, you guys are elitists
with your geography and
your lines on the map.
- It all felt extremely produced.
Like, do you think that was spontaneous?
- I think it was very spontaneous
'cause they were riffing off each other.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- And here's my point, there's something,
I talk about in the book, called midwits.
And tell me why you think
it's not spontaneous.
- Because the way they were
riffing off each other,
these people don't riff
off each other well.
When you see see Lemon and
Cuomo do it, it's horrible.
It's so stilted, you can tell these people
don't really like each other.
They have this awkward
minute between their shows
when they do it and also I
know a lot of these people.
Like you know a lot of these people.
Like the way they are and their ability
to be human on camera, it's not like this.
Literally, it's not like this,
what we're doing right now
where it's like, we have cameras on us
but we're acting basically the same.
You know, there's always
like, you turn the camera on.
What's that theory?
There's a name for that
theory when you a camera on.
I can't remember what it's called,
but we're basically acting like ourselves,
and there's nothing suddenly
that this camera goes off
that I'm gonna, our interaction
would be wildly different.
- As I said at the beginning--
- Right, we went out to dinner
a couple weeks ago, it's this, right?
- As I said at the beginning of the show,
this is how I dress all the time.
- This is exactly what you were wearing.
You were wearing the Tulsi last time--
- No the Malice look
that Tulsi appropriated.
- Right, right, right, I keep forgetting.
So it struck me as the
level that Don was laughing
did not strike me as
uncontrollable laughter.
It struck me as
uncontrollably fake laughter.
- [Michael] Interesting.
- And the way that they
were all bouncing back and forth was like,
they had planned this,
like they need something
to go viral like, I don't know.
You might be right and maybe
it's somewhere in between
what we're both saying.
- Both theories are so stupid
it's hard to figure which
support the reality, right.
I'm hearing what you're saying
and it's completely plausible
that they sat down and did the
worst improv class in history
but there's a couple
of things in that clip
that I thought are very cogent.
There's this concept called
midwits which I mentioned
in my book which is about people
who are marginally intelligent, right.
When you're barely smarter than average
but you are desperate to
demonstrate your brilliance, right?
Because there's very few chances
where you're gonna be the smart one.
If you're six foot you are
tall, you're above average,
but when are you gonna be the tall guy?
Never, so to think that
being able to find Ukraine,
who everyone who's played
risk can be found on a map
as a sign of your brilliance
speaks to your intelligence.
And the other point is
Jim Goad, the writer
who wrote "The Redneck
Manifesto" he made the point
that every single stereotype
that was applied in the past
toward poor, low status
blacks was overnight
by these same people applied
to poor low status whites.
You go back and watch that
clip and those accents
that they do and those voices, those lines
and that book learning,
they're 60 years away
from saying the N word about
the same kind of population.
It's a status thing,
and racism and classism
have always very hand
in hand in this country.
- So then what is going on in their minds
in a segment like that?
Do they honestly think
that they are helping
whatever the cause is that they believe?
- This is what I think, I
think now they are in retreat.
I think they get a lot
of heat on social media
where people call them
out on their malfeasance
and depravity and
they're getting defensive
and now they are being
sarcastic because sarcasm
is often a sign of cognitive dissonance
where your brain has
two contradictory ideas
and can't reconcile them, so
for them the idea that maybe,
I always tweet this at these people, I go,
have you ever wondered if maybe
you're one of the bad guys?
The idea that we're not
better than everyone else,
that we're not particularly
bright, it's true,
but it's very disturbing to
their self-image because hey,
I'm on CNN, I'm on a panel,
clearly I'm brilliant.
And no, Ana Navarro's on those panels.
She's not brilliant.
She's William Howard Taft.
- She's also called me racist
on Twitter, so you know.
- Ana Navarro, comma.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
who's called David Rubin racist, comma,
who sat down with Michael
Malice, comma who was, you know,
who Tulsi Gabbard appropriated the, comma.
It reminds me of something
that happened to me
about a year ago, a good friend of mine
who I grew up with, I
went to college with,
we both studied political
science together.
We'd been friends for our
whole lives, 40-some odd years.
He's a huge lefty now, obviously
we diverge politically,
but we went out for a drink
and we sorta got into it
and he was getting very
heated and I just kept trying
to get out of politics, I tried.
And I'm sure you've been
in a million of these
where you just, you try to let it go
and there's something
that's beyond politics,
and I was trying to talk about his kids
and everything else going on.
And we couldn't get there and
I finally said to him, I said,
"Do you think that I
believe what I believe
"as much as you believe what you believe?"
- Ooh, great question.
- And without pausing,
with no hesitation he said, "No."
and I thought--
- Oh, wow.
- And this is a really--
- Telling.
- This is a really rare moment for me.
It then really escalated and
I've never done this before.
I swear to you I've
never done this before.
- Dave Rubin, comma, who's
never done this before. (laughs)
- I threw money down, I
paid for the whole thing,
the whole tab right
there and I walked out.
I've never done anything like that before,
and it's so counter to, right,
everything you know about me.
But I thought, that moment right there,
like you have to sit in that now.
Like, I'm not attacking your motives,
but you actually believe
that I can't believe
what I purport to believe.
- What's amazing is there is a continuum.
And there's lots of people
who would blurt that out,
and as soon as they heard
themselves say it, they'd be like,
whoa, whoa, whoa, okay, I've
gone down the wrong path.
But the thing is, they've been so trained,
especially the last few years,
if you ask one of these types,
is it possible that Trump
is just crappy, mediocre,
and blame McKinley?
Is that okay with you?
And they're not gonna
really have an answer,
because it's very important
that he is the worst president
who's ever lived, although
there's very few metrics
where you can make that argument.
- Are you finding that there
is an undercurrent of support
for Trump now that did
not exist last time,
that suddenly this thing
has gone so bananas,
everything we've been talking
about for this half hour,
that now there's people that
would have never considered
voting for Trump the first
time that basically still
see the wheels on the machine,
still see some level of pride in America,
still see paychecks that are working
and unemployment that's
low and black unemployment
that's low and Hispanic
unemployment that's low,
and they like getting rid
of some of the regulation
and all of those things,
that we're not in extra wars
and he's trying to get
us out of Afghanistan
and everything else, that suddenly people
that would have been
completely in opposition
to Trump last time.
- I think a lot of them
are just gonna be happy
to stay home.
They're gonna be like, look,
I can't bring myself to vote for this guy.
He's, we can think of all the names,
but I'm not going to endorse this.
Essentially, Biden is the nominee.
I gave Biden money because when he went
in front of these coal
miners and told them--
- Yeah, yeah.
- That if you know how to shovel coal,
you can learn how to
program a computer I'm like,
I need a year of this.
- He literally did the learn to code meme.
But for people that know about this meme,
this was a meme that when what was it?
Was it BuzzFeed when BuzzFeed
was gonna unionize basically?
- They laid off a lot of journalists,
and they're all boohooing.
And then all the trolls,
I use the word trolls
in the good sense just
at-ed them, #Learntocode.
And people got kicked off of Twitter.
- Meaning learn how to
do something productive
instead of being a BuzzFeed employee
and Biden actually brought it to life.
- But he also brought
to life to an audience
where it's not an accurate.
If you know how to write for BuzzFeed,
you could probably have
the technical skills
to learn how to code on a basic level.
If you're a coal miner, that does not mean
you know how to use a computer well.
And by the way, if you're
a computer programmer,
you can't mine coal either.
These do not transition very easily.
I think it was @ComfortablySmug,
who tweeted out
that you do know if there's the debates,
Trump is going to bring
that stripper and put her
in the front row and ask Joe
if he's met his granddaughter,
and it's going to be just complete chaos.
So I hope he's the
nominee very desperately.
- But watching him is
sort of depressing, right?
I know this is where you
wouldn't, it's depressing in that,
for someone that's a little
more old school politics
and not on the fringe of the new right,
that for someone that
like I want the system
to somehow function even
though I always tell you,
it's like I love all the
intellectual adventures
I go on with you, I really do.
But for someone that wants
like some thing to kind of hold
that was somewhat
centrist and we could have
an interesting--
- But that's Biden.
No, but he can't do it anymore.
It seems like he can't do it,
which is why he's telling
these guys to code.
It's why he's saying
you can pick your gender
depending on which jail you want to go to.
- He said that?
- Yeah, at the equality forum.
He said it's not what birth sex you are,
it's what you identify as.
You have an awful lot of male
rapists in women's prisons.
He literally said that.
He was brought in as the
sane guy and he can't be sane
but I think that gets to your point,
that this thing just
eats through everything.
- Right, and again, he
doesn't have that space
within his party.
I can't believe he said
that about the jails.
I mean, this is hilarious.
- I am not making it up.
- How is this depressing to you?
This is glorious, just--
- You know what, I'm
telling my guys right now,
we'll play the clip right now.
- In prison, the determination should be
that your sexual identity is
defined by what you say it is,
not what in fact, prison says it is.
And in that case, you should
be entitled also to OBYGN,
anyway, you didn't ask that question.
You're not likely to either I guess.
- Well, there you go, Malice.
That's the man that you want
to be the Democratic candidate
for president of the United States.
- Desperately.
One of the things that this speaks to
is one of the best
aspects of conservatism,
which is asking questions like,
when you're advocating for program,
what do you do with the people
who will use this program in bad faith
or this law in bad faith?
And very often people on the
left don't have an answer,
or they'll hand wave away like, oh,
there won't be that many cases.
Well, there won't be that many cases,
again, is Nicholas Cruz in
Florida shooting up a school.
It's that outlier, that both moves culture
and also is the destroyer
and that is who we should
be concerned about.
- What else are you tracking right now?
What else is on your
mind that's unearthed?
In the bottom of the internet as well.
- So I've been engaging in like psyops
with a lot of these types.
So for example, when you're
working on a campaign,
you're going to have tunnel vision,
you're living in a bunker, right?
So when there's an article that comes out
in the New York Times,
everyone in the campaign
is freaking out, how
is this going to play?
How the other campaigns, you kind of have,
it's like Plato's cave,
very limited information.
So what I do is, I have a
bigger Twitter following
than many of these campaign
managers for these candidates.
So instead, people tweet
nasty things at them.
That'll strengthen their resolve.
If you're saying oh,
Warren's this and that,
it's like, yeah, I'm
fighting for her against you.
So I will be like, hey, @RogerLau,
latest post came out from Iowa,
five of the six candidates
have solidified their support,
only Warren has lost support.
How depressed are you at the campaign
on a scale of one to Anthony Bourdain?
And then that gets retweeted and you know
it's filling up his notifications.
And he's already having a bad day
and now he's going to be
freaking out even more hopefully.
- So you're instead of
killing them with attacks,
it's not quite kindness
you're killing them with,
you're killing them with sarcasm.
- It's not sarcasm,
this is just a question.
I mean I'm giving the devil on
their left shoulder steroids
and being like more insecurity,
more fear, more freaking out
and just ginning up that kind of.
I mean I can't imagine working campaign
is in a state of constant
stress and panic,
and you're putting out fires all the time.
So let's add some gasoline
and watch it burn.
- How concerned are you
at the social media level,
at the big tech level that
the game has been so rigged
and manipulated already
that we have no idea
what's going on?
I keep mentioning this
thing about shadow banning
is now in Twitter's Terms of Service.
They can literally throttle accounts,
we've known that they've
been doing it forever,
but now they're telling us
they're doing it as of January 1.
And we all just keep playing
the game as if the game
is not being rigged.
- But the game is always
going to be rigged.
I mean when you have your enemies,
to expect them to play
fair is extremely naive.
This is my Soviet mindset talking.
We did have a president
who tweeted his way
into the White House.
And I think what people don't appreciate
is the existential angst it causes someone
who works at a social media
company to see their product
or their program being from
their perspective subverted
by those who they despise,
to further their agenda.
This must cause them a lot of grief.
- But doesn't it also cause
them to tighten those spigots
and make sure that as we
get closer to the election
that Michael Malice isn't
going to be heard as much
or Trump's not gonna be heard as much,
or Rubin or anybody else.
But we all pretend that
that's not really it.
That would be the thing that we would
all be relentlessly talking about, right?
If we really were trying
to change something here?
- I think they are losing
tools in their toolbox.
And I think I mean,
Kamala Harris was calling
for Trump to be banned from
Twitter, remember this?
And she got pushback, even from the left
and when she lost her campaign,
I did a ham tasting on my
livestream and we tried
different kinds of hams
from all over the world
'cause the pig was finally roasted.
So I think they are going
to try different tactics,
but because they're being
called out on their tactics,
instead of being called out on the issues
this is why they are freaking out.
It used to be they would
say, Dave Rubin's a racist
and you would spend months
being, "No, I'm not, no I'm not."
Now it's Dave Rubin's saying
look at their technique
of calling me, Rogan,
everybody else a racist
as a means of preemptively
dismissing them.
So by you calling out their technique,
it loses almost all its efficacy.
- It's funny because like
three years ago, let's say
when Daily Beast or Mother Jones
or any of these awful things,
these, what do you call,
you call them jihadist?
- A jihadi without the testosterone?
- Yes, whenever they were doing,
and they were calling me all these things.
I'd fight back and then
I could occasionally
get them to change one line or whatever,
but then they wouldn't
actually retweet the thing.
They would just change it and
nobody's seen it and whatever.
It's out there, stealth
edit, so then Wikipedia
can grab from it and the rest of it,
but it used to really upset
me obviously when I first,
like anyone that starts getting that heat,
it's hot at first.
And in a weird way now, because
I have a book coming out
in April and I know
what that is gonna cause
that microscope to look at
me or really fine tune on me
is that I'm glad that
I went through it now.
Do you find that too,
that you've been through
a lot of the the hits on this stuff
and it's like that actually
makes you stronger now?
- Oh, and especially it
makes my audience stronger
'cause they love it.
It's like a greatest hits album, right?
So it's xenophobic, racist
homophobe, blah, blah.
I'm from Brooklyn, I'm an
immigrant, you know what I mean?
When I went after George Soros--
- Could you talk, yeah, talk about this
because this is exactly why I think
you're such a great thinker,
truly, this whole Soros thing.
- Oh, it was beautiful.
So some guy from the Atlantic
and I'm not trying to be dismissive,
I generally don't remember his name.
- The Atlantic is pretty terrible.
- But Dave--
- See this is where--
They've been terrible
since Woodrow Wilson,
even before and the
nation, I mean these people
were the ones agitating for World War I.
I mean, you have to go back.
So there is, Rudy Giuliani made a comment
that he's more Jewish than George Soros.
Now, in any other context,
if you were talking
to Jewish people and said
someone can be culturally Jewish
without actually having
to Jewish ethnicity,
as opposed to someone
could have Jewish ethnicity
and basically be a total goy, right.
This is not controversial,
it's very well known.
- And everyone knows this,
Obama kept saying he was
the first Jewish president.
- Yes, this is very known.
We were both Jewish, we know
people who are super Jewish
and people who are basically lost
and the people who are
adopted Jews basically
but like the culture.
And the guy from the
Atlantic was like, ah,
in the world of Trump,
someone can be less Jewish
than somebody else.
And he's saying this about
a literal Holocaust survivor, right?
Referring to Soros, but what
was amazing is in the same way,
it's Dave Rubin, comma, secret
Klansmen and homophobe comma,
it's George Soros comma,
literal Holocaust survivor.
Now, I always say the
corporate press is factual
but not truthful.
It is factual that George
Soros survived the Holocaust,
he was Jewish, he was
in Hungary I believe,
he was under Nazi occupation,
his life was in danger.
However, in any other context
people would not even argue.
The experience of Jews who
fled Germany and got to America
is not the same as the experience of Jews
who survived occupied territory,
is not the same as a Jew
who escaped the camps
or survived the camps.
These are three, they're
all Holocaust survivors,
these are separate things,
but by using that term,
they're trying to say George Soros,
multinational billionaire
is beyond criticism,
specifically because of the Holocaust.
And they came at me blah,
blah, blah, and like, look,
I was born in Ukraine,
my family survived the
Nazis and the commies,
I went to yeshiva, I've been
circumcised three times,
you're not gonna outjew me.
- That's pretty excessive.
- So some guy came at me and he's like,
oh, my grandfather died in the Holocaust,
family history doesn't matter,
sometimes you could just be a jerk.
And I go, I paused, this
is one of the few times
I paused before I tweeted.
I go, I was wondering
who died and made you
an insufferable prick
but now I guess we know.
Because you are not going to
wave your grandfather's ashes
at me to win some Twitter
beef to defend George Soros.
And I said to the Atlantic guy, I said,
if you want to make George Soros out
to be some sort of modern day
Anne Frank, I can't stop you.
But this is what they do all the time.
It was really funny,
especially Kamala Harris
is a great example because they
can't figure out a criticism
if it was racist or sexist.
So whatever the, there's
only like 10 words to use.
And once you say I'm not even
having this argument with you,
they have no power.
- But isn't it the irony
that it's also the people
that find bigotry everywhere can't find it
when it's actually right there?
- Oh, sure.
- This happens constantly.
I mean Soros is such a great example.
The guy's given hundreds
of millions of dollars,
if not billions of
dollars, to all these NGOs
that basically are just
trying to destroy Israel?
This is not, so he may be Jewish,
but is he a friend of the Jews
or whatever that even means,
by any logical explanation.
- Even if he literally was
taken out of Auschwitz,
and thankfully he was,
he had a much easier,
certainly I don't wish
that on anybody almost,
the idea that a billionaire
is beyond reproach.
I mean, this is the number
one person, Koch brothers,
Soros, Sheldon Adelson, these
are the number one people,
Tom Styer, who should
be subject to scrutiny,
because they're using
their wealth to influence
the political process.
That's the number one
person that you want to look
at with skepticism.
So to have them run interference for Soros
in the name of the Holocaust
was so off putting to me
and I was very glad that I'm like,
I'm not backing down from these
efforts, not for one second,
and I didn't and it was great.
- Yeah, you didn't.
What do you make of the billionaire crew?
So the Bloomberg, Styer crew
that desperately want in
on the DNC now, or what's
happening with the dems?
And it's like you guys,
do you have any idea,
even if you could buy the nomination
what the radical activists
will do to you at the end?
- Tom Styer--
- What a loser.
I mean, you're gonna be a billionaire
and he's just, he stands
there with Bernie like,
please don't throw me
in the pit of Sarlacc,
in the pit of Sarlacc.
- The republicans we had
back in the day, Maury safer,
Maury Taylor.
- Yeah.
He ran I think in '96 or something,
he was some kind of big businessman.
It is, watching Tom Styer
talk, and it's like,
it's very cute because when
you reach a certain amount
of money, right, my understanding
is, you will have people
who will tell you what you want to hear
in order to be your consultant.
So they sat down with him
like, yeah, yeah, Trump did it.
Why can't you?
So I think it's fun to watch him
but I don't think he's gonna, Bloomberg--
- What do you make of the way
he kisses the ass of the socialist?
Doesn't it just strike
you as the most pathetic?
- No, I think this is the guy who,
there's a lot of these types.
They made it on Wall
Street, but they want to be
with who they perceive
to be the cool kids.
And now he's on stage with Bernie
and I think he's genuinely excited.
- Oh, it strikes me as so pathetic.
I don't even think you're
wrong necessarily--
- I think it's cute.
- But the idea that this guy, Bernie,
who really has so many counter
ideas to what allowed Styer
to become a billionaire,
and he just gets up there
and he's like a little
yipping dog around Bernie
and Bernie is always like shoo shoo.
It just seems so pathetic.
- Listen, when Tulsi
followed me on Twitter,
there may have been shrieking and running
back and forth in my home.
I'm not in a position to judge Tom Styer
to be excited to be debating Bernie.
- Where do you think Bloomberg
fits into this whole thing?
'Cause every freakin'
ad on YouTube right now
is a Bloomberg ad.
I mean, this guy is throwing every dime.
- But he's got a track record.
- Yeah.
Like of all of them, he actually
has a great track record
to run for president.
And here's, amazing, he's got 50 billion,
and he's only spending like one billion.
It's like what do you need
the other like 26 billion for?
- So does he strike you then
as when I asked you before,
well, what does the sane left look like?
Or if they can get out of this thing?
What does that moderate
democrat look like?
That seems to be far more Bloomberg
at this point than Biden.
- I wouldn't say that
because I think Bloomberg
is really a zealot when it
comes to his biggest issue,
which is the guns.
- Don't forget the sodas.
Well, no, that's not, he
doesn't talk about that anymore.
He really wants the guns--
- Bu he tested the gun
thing with the soda thing.
- Yeah, I guess that's
one way of looking at it.
So when it comes to that,
like in their sociology,
the gun is a heretical object
and can never be treated
as positive or even neutral,
it has to be kind of like cursed.
And you don't show it in a
positive light whenever possible.
So he's really drank the
flavor aid on that one,
and that's what makes him quite dangerous.
- Okay, but if you remove the gun one,
and I completely hear you on this.
I mean, even just the, there
was the shooting at the church
and basically, Bloomberg
was condemning the guy
that shot the shooter.
- But the thing is if
you remove the gun thing,
he's not running.
The problem with these types is the thing,
the one issue that is the
problem is the one issue
they care about.
- So that would be like Styer
and climate change, right?
'Cause he just gets up there--
- Right, that's his only,
the only thing that matters.
So like when Elizabeth
Warren starts talking
about transgender rights,
she doesn't care about that,
this is something she,
at age, how old is she?
70 something, you don't at age 70
suddenly realize that
you want reparations.
That's not a thing, this
is something she's like,
all right, I gotta, I
think she saw in 2016
two very vino people get the nomination
and she's like, all right,
this is what politics is,
I'm gonna have to sell my
soul and basically out Trump
and out Hillary both of them,
and she's doing a piss poor job of it.
- Do you sense that the train left
the station on reparations even?
They were talking about
it a couple months ago
at the early debates, and even now,
it's not being talked about almost as if
enough people were like, no, no, no.
- I mean, they just, it's
insane because basically--
- But they don't need the logic behind it,
they just have the issue, right?
So it's not like the money or the numbers
would have had to have mattered.
- Sure, but I think also a lot of people
in the black community realized
that the Democratic Party
often takes them for granted.
I think that often what that
was trying to be a wedge
to get black voters who were
very pro-Obama obviously,
who are going to be for Biden,
to pull them away from him
because he's not I don't
think for reparations
or at least yet and I think
it was kind of a lead balloon.
Because I agree with you.
When you have even the
Central left hearing this
and being like, what
are you talking about?
This is not even practical
even if you want it to happen,
yeah, that's when they
pulled back a little bit.
- It's never good in a
society when you're going
to be judged and condemned
by your father sins, right?
Or not even your father,
your grandfather's
grandfather's grandfather.
Nothing good gonna come
out of that, right?
- All right, I mean at a certain point,
it's just basically like we're gonna,
it's almost explicitly, we're
going to take money from them,
whoever them happens to be
and give them money to us.
And then we're gonna find
some ex-post facto reason
why this isn't just necessary
but the moral thing to do.
This is as night follows day.
- You're feeling pretty good
about things I can tell.
- I am so, if there's one
group that I want to reach
and I talk about this
constantly on social media
and my work, it's people
who are black-pilled.
Black-pilled is the idea
that all hope is lost.
And I think things are so exciting online.
It's so exciting in your culture
and things are so beautiful,
and can I use a curse?
- You can.
- We have a shit poster as president.
- You just asked me if
you could say shit poster?
- Well no, I'm going to
lead up to the N word.
- Oh, okay. (laughs)
- When we have a shit poster
as president, it is so,
every day you wake up, you're
like, how is this real?
And when you have the left
now understanding the nature
of the corporate press and
becoming red-pilled and like,
I welcome them with full love
in my heart and open arms,
like join us, like they're the enemy.
Me and you are not the enemy.
We might disagree, but we're
not each other's enemies.
- Is that also part of it?
I think that, so I'm with you.
I think there's something
so hopeful right now,
I've been talking about
how there's so much
fertile ground for ideas.
There's so many interesting
people popping up
all over the place.
I didn't know who you were two years ago,
there's so many cool--
- I can say the same.
Come on, you must have known me.
- I was on YouTube--
- The famous racist.
Comma, racist, blah, blah, blah.
But yes, there's so much good and yes,
there's a part of our brain I
suppose that gets us focused
on the fighting and the
negative or whatever that is,
even though I know you think that fighting
is good and whatever.
But the other part of this is the people
that I'm most sort of
interested in right now online,
are the people that are not
purely obsessed with this.
So there's like a certain
crew that just even
that I think are smart politically,
but they just tweet
politics every fucking day
over and over and over, and
it's so boring and painful.
And then there's this other
crew and I try to do this,
like my dog's in her last days,
and I post about her a lot.
And I try to post about food
that I'm cooking and other,
then funny and silly things
and things that you're doing,
and it's like, I think people want
to see more complete
people, something like that.
- I think there's such a move
online about self-empowerment,
and making something of your life.
I certainly have been
talking about mental health
a lot more in my social
media, and it's so rewarding
when you're young, to be told
if you want to do it, do it.
Maybe you won't be as
successful a podcaster
as Dave Rubin, right?
But you can be somewhat
successful, and even if you fail,
you're still--
- You still have to do it.
But you're also fighting for
something that matters to you.
And that failure is going
to be very rewarding,
and you and I have both failed
in many things over the past
and you keep fighting, keep
fighting, keep fighting.
So that the fact that
there's so many opportunities
to make something of
yourself be self-actualized,
it's such a wonderful time to be alive.
And I feel so sad for people who don't,
I'm saying, you don't have to
be the best person on earth,
but you have it in your
power to be a better person
than you are now.
And when you put in
those terms, like yeah,
it's just that simple.
- Man, you channeling a
little Jordan Peterson
over there or what?
- Is that what he talks about?
- I mean, it's well, those 12 rules are
to live the best life you can.
I mean, you're channeling
a little Ryan there too.
I mean, you're channeling just this idea.
It's your life, get moving.
- I'm an immigrant.
So the fact that I am in
a position where I can be
on this show, shirtless,
running my mouth--
- You are wearing underwear, right?
- It's a mix.
Having the time of my
life and I think people
who have day jobs who can't
do this crazy stuff enjoy it
and being able to pay
my rent is so exciting
and to be able to tell people look,
there's so much out
there for you to enjoy.
And that's what the
left doesn't give them.
The left, you cannot be this
depressed, angry and anxious
for four years, it's just
not psychologically healthy.
So even if Trump is Hitler, fine.
Find your bliss within
this dystopian America
that you perceive us to be.
- Wasn't that, that movie
"Life is Beautiful",
that was it, right?
- Well, I haven't seen that
movie, but I love that message.
- They were in a concentration camp,
but the father basically kept tricking,
I think it was the daughter
that life is beautiful despite everything.
You gotta find something.
- I will always be Ricky
with the plastic bag
in "American Beauty"
and it makes me so sad
to watch so many people,
'cause the mentality is,
well, I've tried nothing
and it hasn't worked
so I'm gonna give up.
Just try something, something
is out there for you.
- Yeah, and that's what's
so cool about everything
that we have right now, all
of the technology you can do,
I mean, that's the number
one question I get.
I go to colleges and people are like
I want to do what you
do, and I'm like, do it.
I mean, there is literally,
what's the best advice, Dave?
Do it, put some stuff out there.
Don't worry about view counts.
Don't try to just be there
to destroy everybody,
build something cool.
I always tell them build something cool
so that I am forced to
put you on the show.
Force my hand, don't ask me
when you have 10 followers
and you're, make it so that one day
it's like Dave has to
have this guy on the show.
- Right, and give people
something of value.
Be earnest, sarcasm and this sneering
is very, very weak and cheap.
And here's the other advice
and I'm sure you're gonna agree.
I tell people don't strive to excellence,
especially when you're young,
you're not gonna be able to do it.
Strive to competence.
If you're competent, if I can rely on you,
you're at the 80th percentile
and that is within your means.
- Yeah, and that's actually
a counter in many ways
to what people are being told
where you're just outsourcing
everything all the time
and nothing's your fault,
you shouldn't really work that hard
and they'll take care of you.
And it's like we are
given the counter message.
- Yeah, be reliable and you
will have that guest on over
and over again.
I messaged you, I'm like, hey,
maybe I'm tooting my own horn
here, but it was just like,
I'm gonna be in LA, let's do
a show, you're like, sure.
- Well, we tried several other people
everything fell through.
- (laughing) Tulsi canceled.
Tulsi canceled, I was like, who's that guy
that dresses like Tulsi
or she dresses like him?
All right, this is what we're gonna do.
Malice, I have an idea.
It just hit me while we're sitting here
because I find when you're
having a good conversation
like this interesting ideas pop up.
The week before the election,
I wanna do five shows that week.
We only usually do one
or two shows a week.
I want to do five shows;
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday.
I want five unique political
people to be on that weekend.
I'm gonna make two comments here
that I want you to be part of.
I want you to be one of those people
'cause I want five people from
completely different walks
of life and political persuasions,
to just give me like
what's happening right now
before the election.
- Do I have to fill my
eye with blood like Biden?
- Yeah, your eye has to actually explode.
You have to announce that men
should be in women's prisons,
like the whole thing.
So I want you as one of those
people, that's number one.
And number two, I want to
do a post-election blow out
that night, I want you here.
If I have to fly you to
LA, whatever we have to do.
- Okay, we'll do it.
- I will fly you here.
You're gonna have to pay for your dress
or whatever else you're
going to be wearing that day.
We will fly you here and we'll feed you.
- Let's do it.
- Fair enough?
Yeah, absolutely, done.
It was a pleasure, my friend.
And for more on the
hijinks of Michael Malice,
follow him on Twitter,
it's @MichaelMalice.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.